ja wir sprechen jetzt die ganze zeit
über donald trump über seine anhänger
und über seine partei die republikaner
und wollen jetzt genau von dort hören
wie man das alles aufgenommen hat uns
zugeschaltet drei freund von den
republiken saw the seas und herr freund
wir uns gerade von herrn professor jäger
gehört besonders wichtig für die
kommende zeit von donald trump ist es
wie das bei der basis der republikaner
angekommen ist wie ist ihr eigener stand
momentan jetzt zu dem noch amtierenden
präsidenten und was hören sie ansonsten
auch von den republikanern die hat man
das gestern aufgenommen
also man muss ganz klar sagen dass man
trennen würde zwischen dem partei
establishment und dem wähler das
parteiestablishment ist von diesen zehn
wiedergesehen haben abgestoßen lehnt es
komplett ab möchte auch betonen dass
dieser mob denen sie dort bezeichnen
diese chaoten nicht legitimiert in
irgendeiner weise sie nennen sich trump
unterstützen
sie nennen sich amerikaner wie jeder den
bildern zu sehen ist das aber selbst
ernannt da ist nichts offizielles dabei
also insoweit hat sich die partei auch
schon distanziert
von diesen sogenannten anhängern die in
wahrheit gewaltbereite chaoten sind
davon losgelöst muss man den
amerikanischen wähler sehen bei seinen
trump hat die meisten stimmen bekommen
die ihren präsident bekommen hat mehr
als barack obama beispielsweise in
absoluten zahlen aber er hat eben gegen
dass es beiden verloren
das zeigt aber dennoch dass trotz des ko
it-management und trotz seiner seine
auftritte im bereich der rassenunruhen
und der diskussion danach und auch der
sprache die er meiner ansicht nach dort
über übertrieben hat und auch nicht mehr
präsidial war noch vor der wahl hat
trotzdem so ein phänomen das
wahlergebnis hingelegt hat das zeigt wie
stark die leute hinter ihm sind und es
wird sich erweisen den nächsten tagen in
die weinpresse jäger bereit sagte diese
wähler sogar sie in ihnen den wahren
helden sehen oder ob ein teil der wieder
sagen wird hier hat er eine rote linie
definitiv überschritten ich distanziere
mich davon nicht von der
republikanischen partei aber sehr wohl
vom präsidenten
ich mag sie aber gern einmal ganz direkt
fragen präsident trump ist ja mit dem
ticket der republikaner ins weiße haus
eingezogen und wollte es auch
verteidigen gestern haben seine anhänger
nach seiner rede das kapitel gestürmt
schämt man sich dann dafür dass dieser
mann am ende mit hilfe der republikaner
ins weiße haus eingezogen ist
also ich eben tut man sich nicht dafür
man muss an dieser sagen amerika sind
wahlkämpfe personenwahl kennt keine
parteien wahlkämpfe wir haben da keine
parteien im europäischen sinne im
deutschen sinne sondern parteien sind
dienstleister die im jeweiligen
kandidaten unterstützen es gibt 435
kongressabgeordnete 100 senatoren
und jeder muss die absolute mehrheit
gewinnen um zu gewinnen und dann muss
sich vor seinen wählern verantworten
das heißt es gibt keine amerikanische
partei die listenplätze verteilen kann
und oder die sogar eine programmatik
vorgibt
ganz im gegenteil die person
entscheidung die programmatik wir haben
soeben sind sehr anschaulich bei der
demokraten in den vorwahlen ob es
senders wird ob es beiden wird ob es
politisch wird und jeder steht für eine
andere politik und jeder definiert auch
die politik der partei
das heißt die personen sind die
entscheidenden handelnden träger und
eben nicht die parteien als gegeben hin
sollte man das rennen zwischen
handelnden person und partei ich die
persönlich untersuchen und langen auch
bei ihnen in den interviews bin ja eher
anhänger der grand old party also der
zeiten von reagan bush zu der zeit
allerdings trüben gearbeitet studiert
habe und zähle mich er dazu ich bin kein
jump ist oder man sagen muss die tram
pisten wiederum haben jetzt in neuen
kongress innerhalb der partei
prozentual stark gebunden noch eine
frage die bisher von all unseren gästen
ziemlich deutlich beantwortet werden
konnte
wie viel schuld trägt donald trump an
dem was gestern passiert ist oder trägt
er sogar die komplette verantwortung für
das was wir da gestern gesehen haben ob
er macht man sich zu leicht
abgesehen bot präsident tom herkommt er
war eigentlich nicht der anführer war
die folge einer jahrzehntelang
entwicklung dass amerikas mehr sich
selbst bezieht mehr den individual- wie
individualinteressen nach vorne in den
vordergrund stellt und eben nicht das
kollektiv und da war er der ausdruck
dieser bewegung dann hat er sich an die
spitze gesetzt und hat meiner ansicht
nach vor einem jahr spätestens dort auch
die kontrolle über seine eigene sprache
verloren und das haben wir dann erlebt
wie gesagt bereich von top management
aber auch im bereich der rassenunruhen
und dann spätestens hat er für mich noch
vor der wahl eine rote linie
überschritten
das haben sich auch mehrfach mitgeteilt
also ich denke es ist auch jetzt für
sein image
alles was passiert ist ist so dermaßen
im hinderlich ist also eine weitere
kandidatur nach meinem dafürhalten in
vier jahren absolut ausgeschlossen